good morning everybody welcome to the
American Enterprise Institute and on
Yelp let go I'm the senior vice
president for foreign and defense policy
studies here at AEI and it is really an
honor for us to welcome to the director
of the Central Intelligence Agency Mike
Pompeo to AEI for I think the first time
in this current role in this current
role so I'm gonna read your bio this is
something that I don't always do those
of you who know me know that I tend to
kind of race through but I sat down and
looked at the directors bio this morning
and I was really enormous ly impressed
so I'm going to read it even and
embarrass you so sworn into sworn in as
director of the CIA in January of 2017
mr. Pompeo was a congressman on the
house permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence and the Committee on Energy
and Commerce prior to that he served on
the House Select Benghazi committee but
before that he was in business for
himself he headed up his own company and
he was a graduate the number one in his
class from West Point served with the
4th ID and along the Iron Curtain when
we still had an Iron Curtain although
were well on our way back and graduated
after serving in from Harvard Law School
where he was the head of the Law Review
that's pretty impressive so really an
honor to have you as a serving in our
government and and delighted to see it
now normally I would give you a little
bit of a rundown on what the director
was going to say but unusually perhaps
in this administration I have absolutely
no idea no leaks out of the CIA what's
happened you've imposed a kind of a
discipline on everybody that is just
heretofore unknown the directors gonna
come up here he's going to speak for a
little while and then he's gonna sit
down with AEI zone marked Eason for a
conversation with mark and then some
questions for the audience so without
further ado mr. director
[Applause]
good morning everyone today is in fact
exactly one year in a few hours it'll be
one year to the minute when I was sworn
in as the director of the CIA I was
supposed to be the weekend before but
you know how the Senate goes held up
across the weekend
Danielle thanks for the kind
introduction mark thanks for having me
here I thought I'd spend a few minutes
this morning talking about that year
that you're from the Central
Intelligence Agency's perspective you
know it's been a very different role
than I had although I did serve on the
House Oversight Committee as you
described Danielle so I had a chance to
see the CIA as a member of Congress but
and I've told my friends that are still
on the committee it is not possible to
gain a full the full perspective of what
the US intelligence services
collectively can do until someone gets
the incredible privilege like the one
that I have to lead one of those
organizations nothing can possibly
prepare you for the breadth to depth the
scope the scale the magnitude of the
efforts that we undertake each and every
day as the nation's first line of
defense I'd go back to the president's
inaugural speech he talked about this
being the hour for the American action
and at the CIA I have tried to live that
and have my team live that we're doers
at CIA trying to stay on the right side
of decorum but we just get stuff done
and I think if the American people had
the capacity to see that each and every
day and they can't for good reason they
too would be as proud of the men and
women who've joined the CIA as I am
I came to quickly understand too that I
wasn't going to improve the courage of
our officers the skillset of our
officers although we're working
diligently to take it to even the next
level but having led to small businesses
having been a leader in the military I
could
that there was a bureaucracy that was
preventing them from being unleashed
from doing the very things that they
were directed commanded and indeed
America needed them to do and so I
wanted to I wanted to be part of
changing that understanding I want to
make sure our officers appreciated the
fact that we were going to have an
expectation nearly every day that we
were going to steal secrets
that's what Espionage services do we ask
her a lot of our officers to risk their
lives to steal secrets to protect
America
it's our fundamental mission we will
never shy away from it and we do so
aggressively and without any apology but
it wasn't enough for me to talk about it
we had to start to implement it so we've
tried to do that one of the things that
we have done you all have seen this in
every organization you've ever been a
part of it is true in government but it
was true in the private sector when I
led there as well bureaucracies just
simply slow stuff down government's
worse in the private sector because
incentive systems are misaligned and so
I led by example 40% of the decisions
that were previously made by the
director of the CIA no longer are made
by me you might say Wow
that's reckless I would tell you it was
reckless to do it the other way we made
careful decisions about which pieces to
keep if it had significant risk cost
political military risk to lives or
officers that's important for the
director to have if the director brought
a special knowledge to bear if I had an
experience set or if it needed full
input from all of the intelligence
community or the broader US government I
I sit as a member of the cabinet then
then I'd keep that decision but if it
was coming to me just because I was the
next fella on the chain of command then
that's a mistake because I would
inevitably slow it down and I would not
be in a position to enter any value to
that decision-making process I spend a
minute talking about that my role I have
tried to impart that same thing
everywhere in our organization I have
asked every leader to make sure and
empower the people that
work for them and I have tried to
encourage the people that work for them
to go grab that authority if we do that
we'll be as fast as our adversaries I've
told the story once before I was sitting
in a very long meeting with some very
senior officials and I was asked boy if
we did X what would our adversaries do
and I responded by saying they sure as
heck won't have a meeting like this yeah
that's the that's exactly I was met in
the meeting - a little laughter and some
real concern but everyone knew I was
right as well we need to have a bias
towards being as nimble as over
adversaries if we don't we will serve
America poorly and we won't steal the
secrets that our president and our
senior policymakers most need at the
most challenging times here's another
good example we were forced by
circumstances on the ground to close
down one of our operations a station the
team came and said here's what I think
we're gonna lose we all found it
unacceptable and I gave the commander's
intent I said we're gonna be out we're
gonna move out of that station we're
gonna set the date and we aren't gonna
lose a thing go figure out a way to do
it and remarkably now some months later
I can tell you that our intelligence
postures actually equal to where it was
we did some remarkable things some
creative things some things that
absolutely had real risk and continued
to but it's in a place and on a subject
about an adversary that we simply
couldn't afford afford to have a gap any
larger than the one that we had before
that facility went away I remember - I
remember when Assad used chemical
weapons against his own people the
president called me personally and said
Mike I want to know what happened there
it took us some number of hours before
we could deliver to the president a real
response a substantive response that
could answer the key questions it was
clear from what I'd heard from the
president he wanted to take action in
response to the chemical attack what he
needed to know it was the regime he
needed to know that it wasn't that
chemical
weapons they were in fact used against
civilians those sound easy everyone
could see the open source material but
we all know for a president to act you
need more than that we put together a
team that amounted to the hundreds that
worked every intelligence channel and we
were in just a short order able to
deliver to the president the three basic
facts he needed to know with the
certainty that I could stand in front of
him and commit that he would not we
would not later find that we were wrong
and they had acted in air and we
delivered it to him in a way that
represented the finest of what this
agency does if I can leave one thing
behind is the director maybe next year I
can stand here and tell you that we've
even made more progress it would be to
be as agile and as speedy as we need to
the second thing would be is to ensure
that we continue to keep the American
people's trust it's in law and as I was
reading in preparation for my
confirmation hearing it continued to
strike me how much power and authority
are granted to the director of the
Central Intelligence Agency and through
that to our remarkable officers we have
an obligation to do everything we can to
operate in a way that engenders the
American people's trust so that those
powers and authorities remain in place
if we don't if we behave in ways that
are lawless if we behave in ways that
you might see in the movies then the
American people would rightfully take
those powers that authority that
capacity away from us that would be
unforgivable for our agency to find
itself in that place what we do is
simply too important I see it with
against whichever target we're working
whether its efforts to help the
Secretary of State the president
understand what's going on in North
Korea
whether it's our efforts to counter
Iranian influence throughout the world
whether it's work we're doing against
Russia those authorities that that trust
that the American people have improv I
did to us or central to us achieving our
mission and so days like today which are
few and far between when I come out of
Langley and speak publicly
it's important for the American people
to understand that we operate inside a
democracy that we respect the rule of
law a plea that we have processes in
place to ensure that we continue to do
that and that we are working diligently
to make sure that the people entrusted
with ensuring that's happening in
clandestine spaces our oversight
committees and the executive branch in
which we work are fully informed of the
things we're doing everyone everyone in
my organization would know that's my
imperative my directive to them and I
believe we're doing that in a way that
the American people ought to be
incredibly proud of they're there there
are a handful of stories I may wait for
mark to come up here and I'll tell a
couple of them but you should know that
we are focused on the same set of
priorities that if you had the Secretary
of State to the Secretary of Defense or
the president standing before you today
we would be very closely aligned it's
been in the news some last year it was
remarkable see a creativity which has
now led to our capacity to materially
impact the capacity of the American
government to interdict shipments into
North Korea we're not quite where we
need to be our mission is not complete
but we have officers all around the word
world working diligently to make sure
that we do everything we can to a
support the US pressure campaign and to
tighten the sanctions in such a way that
we have the opportunity to prevail and
achieve the America the American
president's mission which is the
denuclearization of the peninsula that
this is the kind of task if the CI was
designed for that's the kind of task
we're delivering against I talked last
week about the fact that North Korea is
ever closer to being able to hold
America at risk I said that was a
handful of months I had said the same
thing several months before that I want
everyone to understand that we are
working diligently to make sure that a
year from now I can still tell you there
are several months away from having that
capacity
it's not a static time frame there is
much effort all across the United States
government to ensure that Americans
don't have to feel at risk we saw what
happened in Hawaii it is an imperative
an American national imperative that we
as an intelligence agency deliver the
information to our senior leaders such
that they can resolve this issue in a
way that works for the American people
look I'll pause here and take questions
for Marc and others as we move into 2018
I want you all to know that we're going
to continue to do remarkable things on
behalf of the American people we aren't
just focused on North Korean Iran we're
working diligently to solve problems in
Venezuela and problems in Africa our
mission set is broad the
counterterrorism fight which I have not
yet mentioned continues say as a central
part of making sure that policymakers
understand the threat and how best to
attack it frankly I have to tell you I
came in looking at several of these
problems and realized that frankly we
had been whistling past the graveyard
for decades on some of these and you
should know that when I say decades that
is Republican presidents Democrat
presidents Republican congresses of
which I was a member and members of
Democrats who are members of our
legislative branch as well some of these
need to be taken off the table we need
to reduce this risk and CIA is prepared
to do its part to ensure that those
risks are reduced and that that we
ultimately can stare at these problems
with fewer resources consumed because we
have actually resolved many of them mark
I look forward to our conversation and
thank you all for being here today
[Applause]
see well thank you Mike for for being
here at a you've been a longtime friend
of the organization and so we're proud
to have you here that's one of your rare
public appearances
so in there's been a see all these media
people Becca had stood in for a long
time so we've had a lot of people
without first-hand knowledge commenting
and writing books and otherwise about
the president's briefing practices you
briefed the president almost every day
as part of the presidential Daily Brief
so I'd like you as someone with that
firsthand now is to take us inside the
it's but a little time on this take us
inside the president's Daily Brief how
does it work how does he receive it what
kind of a consumer of intelligence is he
so so nearly every day I get up get
ready read the material that's been
presented early in the morning and then
trundle down from Langley to the White
House we present the president with the
most exquisite information any
policymaker it would ever have the
privilege of having a chance to read
that's the mission set every day for the
analysts that prepare the book and it is
it's it's it's quality material I'm
there general McMaster is their director
coaches there have a professional
briefer with me as well a CIA officer
who attends the briefing as well vice
presidents there when he's in town
that's the gang that's usually assembled
before the president someone shouts
Pompeo you're in and I take a deep
breath and then we we deliver it to him
we three buckets really so we will try
and this doesn't happen each day because
the world is two to varying but he said
we try to do something that's that's of
the moment that as we'll talk about
things that happened overnight for
instance today you can imagine we would
have talked about what's taking place in
a free turkey the Turks
moving south out of Syria and then we'll
try also to talk about something that is
coming up so for instance preparing the
president for his trip to Davos so our
foreign leader who's coming to visit or
provide him with material that we know
he's going to confront in that day
or weeks ahead and then we create some
space as well some space to do knowledge
building for the team
strategic items things that that
wouldn't be confronted that won't be in
the news tonight or next week but that
we know are central to having a shared
fact back base understanding across all
of the agency and so those would be the
three types of information the president
asks hard questions he's deeply engaged
will have rambunctious back and forth
all aimed at making sure we're
delivering him the truth as best we
understand it'll ask questions from time
to time that we frankly don't have the
answer to we didn't bring it or we just
we weren't as complete as we needed to
be we'll go back and and within a couple
hours deliver that information as best
we can it is a it is a process the
process that we go through with the
president each day is a process that it
is my hope every senior policymakers
doing with the various briefers that we
have throughout the administration I
hope they are all consuming the
information that we're delivering we
spend a lot of money on it in the same
way that the president does yeah you
said you had some stories and we had
talked earlier whether there was
possibility you could declassify a few
things that that have been discussed in
the PDB but is there an example or any
examples of times where the president
has pushed back on you and pushed you to
get more information and you've been
able to change the outcome of something
or you know and I know this is the most
sensitive the sense of debriefing there
is I'll give you a couple of examples
the president was very concerned about
the humanitarian issues taking place in
Yemen the risk of cholera and the
starvation that was taking place and he
kept pushing us about what was really
taking place on the hand what was the
real lay out what was happening in the
port what was possible given the
configuration of forces on the ground
and he he pushed us at a couple three
days until we were able to deliver him a
satisfactory picture where he then could
make a decision about which of our
friends to call to try and make sure
that that problem was at least
diminished or mitigated you know there's
a second example I remember it was a
little bit before that it was on
Venezuela
the president was dissatisfied with the
description of the situation as we had
laid it out for him and so we kept
coming back it with some financial
issues he wanted more clarity on who had
the money where was the debt what was
the timing of that there were multiple
pieces the array of the maduro and his
forces he wanted to really understand
how they all came together so he could
have a complete picture and it wasn't
long thereafter that would have been the
first or second set of sanctions that
the administration put in place were
enabled by the very intelligence that we
had delivered and he had requested so as
you know I mean president different
presidents take the presidential Daily
Brief differently President Obama didn't
take it in person more than half the
time and it seemed like it during the
transition that President Trump was
going to sort of follow that model he
said you know why do I need to take get
the same people telling me the same
thing over and over again for every day
for eight years and so wonder wonder is
he that's obviously changed so what are
how often does he take the presidential
Daily Brief as a daily and in what are
his briefing habits it's not daily but
it's near daily happened today happened
yesterday it will happen most days it
depends on the president schedule will
often do always traveling too although I
don't travel to deliver that myself will
have a briefer provided to him
schedule for about half an hour often
goes on for 40 minutes or so depending
on the president's schedule how did how
did he become convinced of the need for
it I think it's about value I think I
think in life we all end up with our
schedule shaped by things that are
proving valuable and executing our jobs
so the meetings that I take today are
very different than the meetings that my
predecessors took my battle rhythm is
different than his this presidents this
presidents pattern of taking this
information is different than President
Obama's I've done a little bit of
historical reading it's different than
President Clinton's as well and I think
the reason he does it is because he
finds value that is we're able to
convince him that the facts we're
delivering impact his capacity to
perform his mission I think the day that
we can't I think the day that we can't
deliver that would be the day that it
starts getting pushed off and other
things begin to occupy that time and
I tell my team as they're preparing for
what it is we're gonna substantively
brief we have a big process and
elaborate process that picks those
topics we have to make sure that the
information we're delivering meets the
threshold for the President of the
United States and is delivered in a
manner which he can grasp sufficiently
to actually be able to act upon to
provide real value not just data not
just some set of random facts but real
data that he can use to formulate policy
if we do that I'm convinced we'll
continue the pattern that I think I
think is serving America well today how
is he how do you see him as a consumer
of intelligence is he a sophisticated
consumer of intelligence and what do his
his your interactions with him in that
in that setting tell you about him as a
commander-in-chief I have seen
twenty-five-year intelligence
professionals receive briefings I would
tell you the president Trump is the kind
of recipient of our information at the
same level that they are look I earn a
lot every day too I still you can ask me
about certain places in the world I need
to get up to speed right none of us come
with an encyclopedic knowledge of the
world and the world moves fast enough
that what we knew yesterday or a year
ago is of only modest modest interest
today things move awfully fast he has
the he has the grounding for him to be
able to grasp this information in a way
that he can ask sophisticated questions
that Lent then lead to important policy
discussions I watch it mark will be
sitting at a National Security Council
meeting talking about a particular topic
and he'll bring up something that i
briefed him on weeks or months ago it
could be that he knew that before that
I'm gonna take full credit for having
been the source of that knowledge but
I've seen this time and time again so
it's not simply the case that this is an
exercise he's using it he's taking it on
board and I'm confident that our team is
delivering in a way that's delivering
value to the president and to not just
him but to or other senior policymakers
it is the fact that so many people
underestimate him actually a valuable
asset in terms of national security
that's it's often said you know people
underestimated george w bush
see student from Yale and all the rest
he wasn't that smart he was actually a
very smart man does that is that a
useful tool in national security that
people are interested meeting him III
don't know lots of us have been
underestimated many times okay so keep
plugging all right well let's let's talk
about your leadership of the CIA you
recently said that your goal is to make
the CIA more vicious more aggressive
more inclined to take risks to come
directly at the threats of America in
the world faces how are you making the
CIA more vicious more aggressive and
more risk less risk-averse in the fight
against terror it's all about incentives
it's all about the things that are
rewarded and every organization I've
ever been part of it is the human
condition that you respond to the
guidance the commander's intent the
incentives that are laid out in an
organization so you use CT as an example
it's important if you say it's a
priority you better mean it and by mean
it doesn't mean just giving really good
speeches about it it means if you care
about something you will apply resources
against it the agency that's money
people technical skill other tools that
we have you will actually take those and
apply them against that problem set when
you operate in a constrained environment
that is we have a finite set of
resources that means you have to
deprioritize something else as well it's
almost almost impossible to avoid that
and we've done it we have said hey here
are the things that matter most to us
reprioritize and we have reshuffled that
people see that and people didn't want
to go to the place where they believe
the mission set is at least say officers
are very much that way and so we've done
that we have said hey here are the
things that we're gonna work diligently
against and here's the outcomes that
we're going to deliver for the president
for the country and we have prioritized
that way the second thing I've done I
yeah ten you talked about this a little
bit I ran a company that sold equipment
to the oil and gas industry before I
came to Congress it was the last job
that I had before I I worked with
companies that were drilling for oil and
natural gas best companies in the world
smartest engineers most talented people
and they drilled dry holes
all the time they didn't cry they didn't
punish the engineer who'd made that
choice of that selection they got up the
next morning tried to do a little bit
better and make sure the next one
returned to something I want to create
that culture here at CIA too if we're
gonna do it right if we're gonna do this
well we're gonna have failed missions it
is inevitable almost almost by
definition I'm an engineer by training
almost by definition if you move out on
the risk profile you will increase the
number of times you will have failure
we're gonna do that and we're gonna
we're gonna make sure that people aren't
punished for that
but they are rather recognized for
having been professional for how I have
been operated against the target set and
having done something incredibly
audacious and if it turns out the coin
just ends up tails instead of heads
Soviet we're gonna go next day and go
crush our adversary one more time that's
great um last time you were here today I
fer where we have this kind of a
conversation the topic was Guantanamo
you were a congressman you had just
returned from Guantanamo Bay and you
made the point that far from closing a
long time ago it does yeah but see but
it you made the point that far from
closing it we ought to be filling it
with new people when are we gonna get
some new residents at Guantanamo Bay
yeah
well I can't answer that one of the
glories of being the CIA directors
you're out of the policy world here's
what I can from my perspective now
here's what I can say for the CIA what
is important is that if we're going to
take down networks we need the
opportunity to engage with individuals
from whom whom have been pulled from the
battlefield we need to make sure at the
time the space the capacity to take
onboard the information that these
individuals may well possess and so US
government policy if we are serious
about these fights must reflect that we
have to make sure that not just the CA
but all but DoD and all of the others
who have a part in the counterterrorism
fight have that opportunity and so I am
working diligently inside the
administration to make sure that we have
that how that will play out how how
Congress will what
Congress will definitely have its say
here right today we have a set of rules
for interrogation purposes we have the
Army Field Manual for detention purposes
DoD has the authority that seems that
seems fine to me
but the moment I have officers come to
me and said will we miss something we
missed an opportunity to conduct an
interview on someone who I believe had
information that could save an American
life
we're going to begin to move heaven and
earth to make sure is something like
that does not ever happen again
so since President Obama ended the CIA's
interrogation program we've captured and
interrogated very few people in the
government we've relied more and more on
signals intelligence but our signals of
capability has been decimated by leaks
in recent years and your predecessor
Mike Hayden pointed out recently that in
an age of end-to-end encryption which is
increasing what we're getting
we're signals to intelligence is going
to be getting less content and more
following what he calls digital exhaust
can we keep the country safe without
content and doesn't that suggest that we
need to start getting human intelligence
again in a way we weren't we haven't
been a lot of predicate sin your
questions yeah I love general he's a
dear friend we're still doing pretty
good collecting signals intelligence
mostly our partner not the CIA but we
have a small role in that as well but
that does not foreclose the absolute
imperative that we continue to improve
our capacity to collect human
intelligence that includes human
intelligence through lots of different
forms not the least of which is the
capacity interview those folks who've
been pulled from battlefield so there's
lots of ways to collect human
intelligence we should we should not we
should not put ourselves in a position
where we are we're making decisions on
the assumption that we can't detain an
interview to improve America's
information saying so the Trump
administers talk about North Korea the
Trump administration obviously inherited
a mess in North Korea that as he's
pointed out is gone and both Republican
and Democratic administrations preceding
it and so for you could argue that for
last 25 years kicked the can down the
road on North Korea and now we're out of
road
and this is coming to a head how how did
how does North Korea's missile program
jump from a dozen unsuccessful tests a
year ago to the state that it's in right
now and is is that alarming in the sense
that are they getting it a build rate
where they can actually will be able to
overpower our ballistic missile defense
capability and what do we do about that
so I can't share much with you about
this okay other than to say this they
have moved at a very rapid clip make no
mistake about it they're testing their
testing capacity is improved and their
the frequency that they have tests which
are materially successful has also
improved putting them ever closer to
replace where Americans can be held at
risk I think that's a true statement
it is also analytically true that Kim
drug you will not rest with a single
successful test right the logical next
step would be to develop an arsenal of
weapons that is not one not a showpiece
not something to drive on a parade route
on February 8th but rather the capacity
to deliver from multiple firings of
these missiles simultaneously and that
increases the risk to American that's
the very mission set the president Trump
was direct to the government to figure
out a way to make sure never occurs does
the CIA assess that Kim jong-un is a
rational actor and we do okay we do and
do you think that he believes that the
Trump administration is actually willing
to use military force cuz the only way
you can have the successful diplomatic
solution is if he feels the threat and
he seems to perceive that he's in
touchable because of what he can do to
Seoul and what he can with what it would
even is conventional capabilities much
less is new emerging nuclear capable is
does he really believe that we'd pull
the trigger and do something to to
threaten him so we're concerned that he
may not be getting really good accurate
information it is not a healthy thing to
be a senior leader bring bad news to Kim
jong-un tell someone you're going to do
that try and get life insurance I
I dare you so so we are doing we're -
we're taking the real-world actions that
we think will make unmistakable - Kim
jong-eun that we are intent on
denuclearization we're counting on the
fact that I'll see it more confident
that he will and and then we will
continue to have discussions about how
to achieve that denuclearization can we
live in a world where Kim jong-un has
the capability to destroy New York or
Washington with a push of a button I
mean is that is that the world that
we're willing to go into so that'll be a
decision for the president ultimately I
think he has been unambiguous about his
view on that is heeda turrible kim
datura ball or a seat or does he want
these weapons for another purpose of
this is this this is debate within the
people who've watched Korea is that does
he want this for regime preservation or
does he want it because it gives him the
freedom of action to do things that are
destabilizing in the region so we've
said the CIA I said this publicly before
it is more than just regime preservation
that we are concerned he will use we
have you we talked about the nuclear
risk all the time that gets the brunt of
the world's attention and appropriately
so but its conventional forces alone
right close to a million under arms
depending on how you count them is no
small thing and so we do believe that
Kim jong-eun given these tool sets would
use them for things besides simply
regime protection and that is to put
pressure on what is his ultimate goal
which is reunification and the peninsula
under his authority mm-hmm and so we
don't think it's the case that he's
simply going to use this tool set for
self preservation we think he'll use it
a way that is either you call it what
you will call it coercive as perhaps the
best way to think about how kim jung-eun
is prepared to potentially use these
weapons there seems to be a perception
that the options in North Korea in North
Korea are nuclear war or letting the
reorg going to a deterrence strategy and
there are options and in between that I
mean if he's a rational actor
and and so and president Trump decided
to do something like a limited strike
like the one he had done in Syria what a
rat a rational actor would not respond
the way the Syrian regime didn't respond
right in the sense that they would lead
to regime destruction so if you're a
rational actor who wants to preserve
your regime are there options to to
address his capability militarily that
don't involve a nuclear war between the
United States and North Korea I'm
thrilled that you asked I'm equally
happy not to answer good and by the way
I have to ask and we all understand when
you can't answer one the American people
should know we're working to prepare a
series of options to make sure that we
can deliver a range of things so the
president will have the full suite of
possibilities the president is intent on
delivering this solution through
diplomatic means it is the focus it has
been uniformly that for now 365 days it
remains so today we are focused like a
laser on achieving that we are equally
at the same time ensuring that they if
we conclude that that is not possible
that we present the president with a
range of options that can achieve what
is his stated intention let's talk about
Iran and sort of related to North Korea
I mean one of the holes in the in the
nuclear deal is old-school
compartmentalization in the sense that
assumption that all the work on the
country's nuclear program occurs within
the country to what extent could Iran
use its cooperate we know that there's
there was North Korean cooperation with
Syria for example in building that
nuclear facility that they that Israelis
took out to what extent could Iran use
its nuclear cooperation with North Korea
to conduct illicit nuclear work like on
warhead design that would advance the
Iranian with Iranian scientists in North
Korea that can advance their program
without necessarily our catching it or
violating li jcpoa it's a real risk we
we think we have a pretty good
understanding of what's taking place
there today having said that I am the
first person to admit that intelligence
organizations can miss important
information
these are terribly difficult problems in
incredibly tight spaces and when you're
moving information sometimes difficult
to detect that information
is moved and so if someone asked me as
the senior intelligence leader of the
CIA
can you guarantee this I would say
absolutely not but we're working
diligently to make sure that doesn't
happen it that's actually harkens back
mark to your previous question about one
of the risks of a lot of North Korean
regime to continue to have this nuclear
capability it is this proliferation risk
it is that this technology that they
have developed and then figured out how
to manufacture at something beyond just
a museum piece that is some form of
production level of their capacity would
then be proliferated proliferated
elsewhere in the world and then
secondarily it doesn't take too much
imagination to understand that if they
continue to have that nuclear weapons
system or if the Iranians make
advancements in theirs that many other
countries around the world would decide
me to write that that I want to have one
of those things that that guy has being
very careful not to identify countries
but you can sure you can go through the
list of those who would feel incredibly
threatened and feel that they needed to
have a similar capacity in order to
defend their own national security
interests sure um let's talk about
Vladimir Putin for a second so this is a
guy who you know who shows up a lot with
his shirt off right here there's the
famous story where he where he saw
Barney and told President Bush she's my
dog bigger stronger you know that is
this is this are these behaviors of
someone who's a strong leader or a weak
leader you know our assessment of
Vladimir Putin's intentions haven't
changed
he continues to view the greatest the
greatest failure of the last century it
had been the dissolution of the Soviet
Union he is bent on returning the former
Soviet Union to its greatness and glory
that's the that's what he wakes up
thinking about each day you might add
being reelected as the second thing he
thinks about each day those are related
and so in some ways that is I think is
he moves about the world he is conveying
back to his domestic audience the
imperial power of the
Russian people he hasn't changed this
administration is deeply aware that we
need to continue to push back against
the Russians everywhere we find them so
look let's talk about a little bit about
the recent news stories about there was
a possible mole within the CIA that
resulted in a loss of a lot of Chinese
assets in recent years and it's harkens
back to losses we had you were stationed
on there on the Iron Curtain
we had losses of agents and Soviet Union
we've had dozen or so Iranian recruits
as a public information in the Middle
East who have been lost the business of
recruiting and running spies is hard but
the records suggest that we might not be
as proficient at it as we ought to be is
this something that needs to get fixed
are we doing well how do you assess
where we are in terms of that we're
never where we need to be I actually saw
this as a member of Congress I came in
as the director a year ago intent on
improving our capacity to protect our
own information we should make sure that
the secrets we still aren't Reese Tolan
right we have an obligation of American
people to do that I've made a number of
changes one of which is to make sure
that we're providing the information so
that the Department of Justice can do
its good work and bringing these traders
to to heel in the US courts the second
of which is making sure that our
organization has the resources it needs
to deliver on its counterintelligence
mission which includes ensuring that
we're doing offensive
counterintelligence that that is working
against our adversary services in a way
that prevents them from getting inside
of our service one of the first things I
did the woman who runs our
counterintelligence mission center
reports directly to me now that was sent
to said that was intentional sending a
signal to two places one to our
adversaries that the CIA is going to be
serious about protecting our stuff and
second to my workforce to know that the
director was personally attentive to a
mission that can that can fall too far
down in the priority scheme there to me
there are a few things more important
than protecting our officers our assets
and our information
it's it's also really hard to penetrate
groups like al-qaeda and Isis I mean the
cold we or the experience and you're
serving on the front lines the cold war
Russian emigre it was either it was it
wasn't a tribal culture in the same way
I mean how hard is it to we back before
9/11 we had almost no human assets I
assume we're we're doing better in that
way but we've got as al-qaeda was was
pushed back then of a sudden Isis
emerged how hard is it to get human
intelligence on these terrorist networks
and the Salafi jihadi movement so
they're all they're difficult targets
for sure but as as the US government has
been successful against them in
different places whether it was a
significant set of successes in the
previous administration against al-qaeda
as we've had significant success taking
the Caliphate away against Isis it
provides us real opportunities to reach
in there are more people who decide
being part of Team America might be
better than being part of Team jihadi
and so we are beneficiaries when those
big disruptions occur and they allow us
to collect in ways that we we can't when
their forces United and we don't have
any chance to touch them so the success
in Syria against Isis has been has been
remarkable in terms of taking away their
physical Caliphate but it arguably
commits a little bit of a price because
we did it with Kurdish fighters which
has caused some tension with Turkey
we've we are perceived at least by the
Sunni population in Syria as being at
least tacitly in an alliance with Russia
and Iran in that fight against Isis
which pushes Sunnis away from us and
towards al-qaeda which is sitting there
waiting
have we been too focused on Isis and not
focused enough on al Qaeda and can we
defeat the global jihadi movement
without bringing suitors into our into
our orbit as can we can we do this with
Kurds and Russians and Iranians or do we
need a Sunni partner on the ground
that's going to fight these guys now we
have absolutely needs city partners and
I think we're working diligently to do
that in eastern Syria the Department of
fence has done good work trying to bring
the Sirk the Sunnis in alongside our
Kurdish partners there as well I think
they made I think they've made real
progress there
this administration has broadly reached
out to Sunni countries all throughout
the Middle East to form coalition's
against not only against Isis but
against Iran as well
and so I think we have made some
substantial progress there if we're
going to be successful at taking down
then she had his threat we will
absolutely need Sunni partners aiding us
in that effort because what worked in
Iraq during the surge was the Sons of
Iraq the fact that the Sunni tribes came
over and it was we were in force enabler
by sending additional troops but it was
really the Sunni uprising against al
Qaeda which was both a military defeat
and an ideological defeat because the
jihadist claimed to be the vanguard of
the Sunni masses and so when they're
rejected by the Sunnis it sends a signal
throughout the region do however weak
are we doing ain't making any progress
in getting a sums of iraq equivalent in
in syria and in some of these other
places where we're fighting them I'm
just go I'll let I'll let others talk
about the progress that we're making
there but you should know that the CIA
understands that our analytic our
analytic assessment is much in line with
what you described it is an absolute
imperative that that we achieve that if
we're going to be successful for the
long run okay one last question I'm
going to turn it to the audience so this
is an that question I asked all national
security policy makers when when they
come through AI so during the 1988
presidential debates
no one asked either candidate about Iraq
and during the 2000 presidential debates
no one asked either Canada about
al-qaeda yet in both of those cases
those two those two elements became
creating crises that became to dominate
the presidencies of George W Bush and
George W Bush what is the threat that's
out there and you see these do you see
threats none of us see but what is the
thing that worries you the most in the
world that none of us are talking about
and no but none of these journalists
here are asking anyone about that that
really could come out and surprise us
and that you worry about at night so we
have these set of things that would be
in the national intelligence priorities
framework and we would all know them
they'd be in the news many days then
there's a set of other things that the
one shouldn't character
second-tier it spite of the fact that
they're not in the new chief news each
day certainly the political wrists in
South America are one of them to make
sure we get that right and that the
United States is watching what's taking
place and frankly every place south of
our border Mexico Central and Central
America and South America and then the
other thing that frankly that the
intelligence community needs to get
right is that some of these threats that
that are real one of them you mentioned
al Qaeda aren't nation states so
historically the threats the United
States in your I'm looking around the
room see how old everybody is your your
history books would have all reflected
threats from countries what was America
doing against the threat from Yugoslavia
or some other nation-state
today the threats are much more varied
than that whether its threats from
groups like Hezbollah or Al Qaeda
threats to our information systems from
groups like WikiLeaks they don't have a
flag at the UN and they present real
threats the United States of American so
we need to make sure that our collection
the way we think about attacking our
adversaries from an intelligence
perspective matches that that means we
have to go back and fix some of the
rules some of the laws that are that are
designed to solve the nation-state
challenge of of history cyber is another
vector it's not a threat of its own but
it is a means by which many non
nation-state actors can inflict
incredible costs on the United States of
America we need to make sure that we are
watching those actors in the same way we
would a threatened from a traditional
nation-state let's take some questions
from the audience
ambassador Roger Noriega it was a
microphone company
good yeah good morning I will see you
again one of the unconventional threats
that we're confronting its transnational
organized crime I know I've been talking
to you about this for for a good long
while in the year that you've been
director have you been has it been a
priority of yours to put more
intelligence resources and going after
the financial network of drug
traffickers and other forms of
transnational organized crime which is
now playing an active role in the
destruction of Venezuela and looking at
influencing elections in Colombia and
Mexico where drug traffickers have a
significant interest in sowing mayhem
and optimizing a supply chain of cocaine
to the market here in the United States
I you could probably add others to the
list I would list the Taliban as well
who uses drug revenue to foment so much
so much pain on the world we have we
have bolstered our capacity there our
collection capacity we've done that
jointly with Treasury Department the
secretary minuchin and his team working
together to take the trade craft that we
have historically used against networks
that look and feel very much like
financial networks and apply them
against those very same networks there's
there's still a long way to go but what
it delivers for policymakers is a set of
options publicly what you'd see would be
sanctions options but in other spaces it
prevents other ways that we can disrupt
because if we know where the money is we
have the capability to stop it flow
we're probably still not at the level we
need to be but we are certainly in a
better place than we were just a short
time ago
I just want note that one of the
challenges will be the recovery of
assets the Chuck Maduro regime is
alluded about 350 billion dollars from
Venezuela being able to recover those
assets and repurposing him giving him
back to the Venezuelan people
reconstruct their country would be
priority 2 thank you there are more than
half a dozen places in the world that I
can tell you we are watching large large
amounts of Wealth's that have been
stolen from the people of that country
and our effort is to identify them gain
the capacity to take them away from the
person who has titled to them today and
then use them for u.s. foreign policy
purposes frankly in most cases to try
and return them to the people from which
they were looted - Nick Goepper staff
director Pompeo how satisfied were you
with the intelligence capabilities on
North Korea that you inherited when you
came to Langley what do you see as the
unknowables what do you see as the
things that are knowable but we don't
know about and should so when I came in
there was insufficient focus on the
problem set it wasn't the case that had
been ignored it wasn't the case that we
had missed material things but clearly
hadn't received the focus and attention
that we're going to be needed to deliver
for what this administration is going to
ask of the intelligence community so we
within weeks of me coming here I created
a Korean mission center stood it up with
a senior leader who had just retired
brought it back to run the organization
that now numbers I can I can see my
information security people over here
there's a lot of folks working on it
we're in a much better place today than
we were twelve months ago we are still
suffering from having gaps part of
that's not the intelligence community's
fault per se this is a difficult target
set so I'll concede that at the outset
but it's never it's it's completely mad
I go for the say they say well that's a
hard problem of course apart bro that's
why you pay us and so we're making real
progress at developing a global
intelligence picture so that we can get
some of those gaps filled in so that we
can understand rates of change so that
we can understand what's happening among
the various leadership elements inside
of North Korea so we can also see
whether the sanctions that have been put
in place are actually having an effect
or sufficient to
fact and an effect on whom that is which
sets of people inside of North Korea and
being impacted and who the scofflaws are
that are preventing those things from
being as effective as they ostensibly
ought to be there is there's enormous
pressure that has been placed on me and
in turn I have placed enormous pressure
on our team to solve the riddle to close
each of those gaps to the maximum extent
we possibly can
Martha hi I want to go back to good to
see you I want to go back to what you
said in the beginning that North Korea
is a handful of months away and I assume
you mean having a nuclear-tipped missile
that could possibly reach the United
States and you said you hope we're in
the same position a year from now that
there are a few months away is that good
enough that in a year from now they
might still be a few months away from
developing that weapon yeah and okay so
what did you mean by that exactly I'm
the president that's the whole it that's
that would be that's inconsistent with
US policy right US policy is that we're
going to denuclearize permanently that
we're gonna foreclose of this risk but
it's the case in the event we haven't
gotten there it is still a secondary
mission to ensure that we keep them from
having that capability and and and I
want to I want to say this - we often
focus on timelines because it's simple
it's not the way we ought to think about
it right the way we ought to think about
it is reliability
can they reliably deliver the pain which
Kim jong-un wants to be able to deliver
against the United States of America
it's it's one thing to be able to say
yes it's possible you could if
everything went right if the missile
flew in the right direction and we got
lucky we could do it as opposed to
certainty right this is this is the core
of deterrence theory you you have to be
certain and the deterrence might have to
be certain that what you aim to deliver
will actually be successful at the very
least you need to make sure your
adversary believes that that it is
certain that's what Kim's Union is dry
before he is trying to put in our mind
the reality that he can deliver that
pain to the United States of America and
our mission is to make the day that he
can do that as far off as possible and
can I just follow up to the Intel
question and and you said a couple of
months away we know the intelligence
before had a far in the future of six
months two years whatever and he was
much faster than you thought
so do you trust do you feel you have
enough information in saying a couple of
months away to be certain and also on
sanctions you said that's a gap
essentially just now the impact of
sanctions the impact the impact of
sanctions owes them do you see any
impact now that you trusted also on the
missile timeline so I can't answer your
second question so I'll do my best to
answer your first it's not that I don't
know I do know I just can't share with
you what we know on the second question
the first one your predicate is actually
wrong you said that that somehow that
the Intelligence Committee got this
wrong we didn't see this coming as fast
as but that's just untrue
I've seen the news articles that have
written that by the way it's not me
bragging this all happened before my
time all of this work the Intelligence
Committee on this one actually
understood the capability and the
testing capacity will never get the week
or the month right on something that's
this complicated but we can get the
direction of travel and the capacity for
rate of change right and we did we
believed we were continuing to deliver
good solid information on the North
Korean missile testing program and all
of the ancillary pieces around it we're
we're pretty confident in that let's
take one more question in the front here
wait for the microphone please thank you
sir I'm Jenny bug with the u.s. a Jenner
recently North Korean Kingdom learn what
so once a dialogue with the South Korea
on the other hand kim giman also nuclear
threat continue to threaten United
States with the nuclear
missiles at the Morris TRUS final
destination of reserve over North Korean
nuclear issues and is it possible to
preemptive strike to North Korea even
necessarily so I leave to others to
address the capacity or the wisdom of
pre-emptive strike from an intelligence
perspective were we're trying to ensure
that all the various options that the
president might want to consider are
fully informed that we understand what's
really going on and the risks associated
with each of those decisions as best we
can identify them okay so yeah we're
just doing that in conjunction to right
we should remember we have partners
there that are working on the Stila G as
well the South Koreans themselves the
Japanese we have partners throughout the
region that share our understanding that
this is a global threat we often here in
the States talk about the threat here
this is a threat to the whole world
okay ladies and gentlemen we have to end
it here I ask everybody to stay seated
while the director leaves and director
Pompeo I know you don't do a lot of
these things we're hugely honored that
you came here to AEI to spend some time
with us and thank you very much for all
your and for your service to the country
[Applause]